m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por cerca de 19 años he venido
trabajando realizando estudios de
mercado para diferentes empresas
nacionales hemos diseñado estrategias
que buscan básicamente ganarse la mente
de las personas pero especialmente su
corazón también escrito infinidad de
artículos relacionados con ese tema pero
lo que es verdaderamente importante y
trascendental para las personas parece
que cada día cobrará menor importancia y
esa es la semilla editorial de la
semilla de mi proyecto editorial de
nominados a soccer el arte de servir
quizás ustedes están esperando una
estrategia mágica y lo que yo vengo a
compartir es un espacio de reflexión en
el que quiero dejarles estas tres
palabras como algo fundamental en el
desarrollo de una marca y la buena salud
corporativa y de una persona
para iniciar quiero contarles que rumbo
al aeropuerto josé maría córdova en
rionegro antioquia e iba en un taxi
quizás por los afanes del mundo
corporativo le pedí el favor al señor
del taxi que parara un momento porque
tenía mucha sed
y entré a la tienda las carreras cuando
salí me percaté este maravilloso
vehículo como ustedes pueden observar
tiene caja de herramientas botiquín
extinguidor y tiene un impresionante
sistema de seguridad
me llamó tanto la atención del vehículo
que dije oiga me voy a mirar a ver qué
es cuando me empecé a acercar la alarma
se disparó y empezó a estar todo el
tiempo y eso me preocupó dijeron mejor
me retiro porque está en riesgo mi vida
decidí voltearme y escuché un silbido
que apagó la alarma
no volvieron a ver más ladridos
y alguien pronuncio de estas palabras
disculpe señor en que le puedo servir la
verdad esta creación parece un vehículo
salido de un cuento de gabriel garcía
márquez y este personaje seguramente
cuando me pronuncia esas palabras
volteo a mirarlo y estaba observando me
con una sonrisa de oreja a oreja lo más
curioso es que me dice oiga venga este
carro que me dice este carro no tiene
muchos caballos de fuerza pero me tiene
a mí y con el recorrido todo el país
para no alargar les tanto el cuento este
señor me dijo estoy terminando mi gira
por el eje cafetero una vez termine me
voy para la costa y me regreso para
bogotá por la ruta del sol yo estoy
totalmente seguro que este personaje
habla ha logrado su propósito acompañado
de su inseparable sistema de seguridad
y eso es lo que convierte la semilla
editorial la semilla para mi proyecto
editorial sa soccer is a soccer es una
palabra que tiene tres elementos saludar
sonreír y servir quizás son las tres
cosas que menos la gente le presta
atención hoy en día porque estamos
sumergidos en tanto afán corporativo que
a esas cosas no les prestamos atención y
qué significan esas o ser vamos a
descomponer las tres palabras cuando
hablamos de saludar eso me lleva a la
época en la que estaba en el colegio y
en mi formación universitaria en la que
nos enseñaron historia geografía
estrategia nos enseñaron liderazgo
inclusive nos enseñaron gestión humana
por ejemplo los administradores de
empresas basados en conceptos como los
de douglas mcgregor que en 1960 escribió
un libro que se llamaba el lado humano
de las organizaciones haciendo
referencia a lo que él llamaba la doble
teoría la teoría x sigue hasta llegar a
modelos como el coaching y diferentes
técnicas de liderazgo y de gestión
humana desafortunadamente no
en mi formación recibí instrucciones o
indicaciones y nadie me enseñó cómo
saludar como decir por favor gracias es
más nadie me enseñó cómo tratar bien a
las personas tampoco nos enseñaron el
buen trato humano si nos enseñaron por
ejemplo protocolos curiosos como decir
doctor o doctora ingeniero o ingeniera
como si eso fuera parte de la educación
con nuestros interlocutores curiosamente
hay personas que nos saludan y para mí
es como si hubiera habido un 'déjà vu'
en la evolución humana es como si
estuviéramos relacionándonos con un
neandertal que todavía no tiene la
capacidad de poder hablar por eso nos
saluda también hemos revisado que hay
personas que tienen títulos y trabajos
doctorales pero ni siquiera así logran
no volver a lo básico que es saludar por
lo menos a las personas
esto me lleva a que reflexionemos que es
lo que estamos formando robots fríos y
calculadores personas cálidas y
respetuosas la verdad para mí es más
importante formar gerentes que valgan
más por el buen trato y por su forma de
ser que por los títulos y distinciones
que pueden llegar a tener
cuando hablamos de esas o ser el arte de
servir también hablamos de la sonrisa
que es un factor fundamental más en el
mundo corporativo de hoy recuerdo que
quino en una de sus caricaturas más
falta decía comienza tu día con una
sonrisa veras lo divertido que es ir por
ahí desentonando con todo el mundo
haciéndonos como referencia a lo
importante que es una sonrisa
y hace unos años le pedí el favor a unos
estudiantes de posgrado que hiciéramos
un estudio social y los invité a que
filmáramos personas y todos me decían
pero profesor que le filmamos personas
en su cotidianidad unas semanas después
de que nos reunimos para poder revisar
el material empezamos a tratar de
encontrar patrones comunes de
comportamiento entre las personas que
estudiamos la mayoría de las personas
iba con cara de preocupación cansancio
estrés y hasta mal genio yo curiosamente
también hice la tarea y me fui a buscar
a este señor un personaje muy popular en
mi ciudad una ciudad de 32 grados
promedio diario que siempre viste de
traje y corbata y lo más curioso es que
camina erguido y lleva siempre una
sonrisa en su rostro es como si él nos
estuviera recordando que para poder que
necesariamente hay que recordar que hay
algún motivo por el cual podemos sonreír
y cuando miramos los estudios que tienen
que ver con la sonrisa los bebés no
sonríen los bebés hacen muecas
involuntarias es algo así como si
estuvieran en modo de prueba aprendiendo
a sonreír y las personas jóvenes como
nosotros reímos en promedio cerca de 400
veces al día pero las personas adultas
solamente llegan a reír solamente 20
veces eso dicen los estudios sin embargo
yo conozco personas a las que nunca les
he visto una sonrisa
y cuando vamos a mirar el mundo
corporativo se tiende a vetar a aquellas
personas que ríen mucho tildándolas de
que no son serias y poco confiables eso
nos lleva a reflexionar a unas palabras
que pronuncian ante un grupo de líderes
de la cámara junior internacional decía
sin madurar implica dejar de sonreír ser
curioso y divertirme con lo que hago
prefiero no madurar
prefiero sonreír haciendo lo que me
apasiona por eso este tema de la sonrisa
es inexistente también en la formación
de los líderes empresariales lo que
debemos buscar es empezar a revisar
investigaciones como la de joe tucci un
científico francés que le dio por
estudiar las reacciones faciales de las
personas al sonreír y el identifico la
sonrisa verdadera la sonrisa verdadera
es cuando usted lleva le lleva los
labios hacia las mejillas y con
seguridad lo que puede pasar es que
levemente se cierren los ojos y
ligeramente muestren los dientes
esa es su sonrisa verdadera y se llama
con sonrisa duche en honor a su nombre
duche también investigó que en la medida
en que las personas puedan sonreír se
generan en el cerebro procesos
neuronales que son curiosamente los que
facilitan el proceso de toma de
decisiones esa toma de decisiones que
hoy en las empresas es la que estamos
utilizando cuando hablamos de la ciencia
de la felicidad hoy en día es un
movimiento mundial y en el último
congreso latinoamericano de la felicidad
se encontró que si las personas viven en
sus empresas felices y están contentas
tienden a ser un 31% más productivas y
un 73% incrementan su compromiso laboral
empresas muy grandes a nivel mundial han
implementado la sonrisa y la felicidad
de su gente como parte de sus objetivos
estratégicos por eso grandes marcas
también empiezan a hacer campañas
publicitarias con el ánimo de robarse un
espacio citó en la en el corazón de las
personas eso que nosotros en mercadeo
llamamos el engagement lograr esa
vinculación emocional y diseñan campañas
para poder dibujar le una sonrisa
personas
otras marcas también diseñan
dispositivos de medición y para llevar
al mundo tecnológico ya no se está
midiendo ni la satisfacción ni la
lealtad de los clientes sino que se
están utilizando unos dispositivos para
escanear el rostro de los funcionarios
que atienden al público y enviarles
señales cuando dejan de sonreír otras
marcas se están diseñando unos
dispositivos para ubicarlos en la
entrada y en la salida de los locales
comerciales con el objetivo básicamente
escanear el rostro del cliente y poder
saber si la experiencia de servicio es
positiva o negativa una vez que él sale
del establecimiento
y en los estudios que he realizado cerca
del 70 por ciento de los entrevistados
manifiesta que durante la atención
comercial nadie le sonrió el 53 por
ciento 58 por ciento manifiesta que no
lo miraron a los ojos pero lo más triste
es que 42% dice ni me miraron ni me
saludaron ni nada porque la mayoría de
los trabajadores estaba mirando su
celular estas tristes estadísticas que
me parecen interesantes de revisar son
las que me llevan a reflexionar qué es
lo que estamos haciendo para realizar
unos procesos de selección adecuados
para poder seleccionar al elegido esa
persona que será la que posiblemente
genere una experiencia inolvidable con
el cliente y pasando a la parte del
servicio
es importante que tengamos en cuenta a
la invitación que les quiero hacer no me
importa que me tilden de agitador pero
debemos recuperar el sentido de la
palabra servir debemos incorporarla en
el adn de cualquier persona marca o
corporación porque curiosamente cuando
uno va a una empresa ahora le dicen que
necesita en que le ayudo en que le
colaboró pero nadie le dice a uno en que
le puedo servir
quizás pienso porque desconocen el
significado de la palabra mágica servir
servir viene del latín servir que
significa de gran utilidad y es cuando
pones al servicio de los demás tus
talentos por eso de qué le sirve a
ustedes en sus empresas contratar
personas con muchos títulos o muchas
distinciones si no tienen actitud de
servicio si no tienen la disposición de
servirle a los demás
quiero invitarlos de nuevo a que
pensemos que las grandes los grandes
cambios de la humanidad no son fruto de
una evolución son fruto de grandes
revoluciones que perturban la armonía
eso que nosotros llamamos el statu quo
porque pasamos del motor de vapor al
motor de combustión
pasamos del mod pasaremos del motor de
combustión al motor eléctrico ya hay
ciudades del mundo donde está prohibido
a partir del año 2025 comercial por
comercializar vehículos de combustión y
así existan infinidad de elementos y
hablemos de empresas 1.0 2.0 3.0
hablemos de chat box apoyados en la
inteligencia artificial absolutamente
nadie podrá cambiar lo que es el trato
humano y la disposición a servir de una
persona para ejemplificar les este tema
traje este libro que es una forma de
mirar gráficamente qué es lo que pasa
cuando hacemos cuando practicamos elsa
soccer cuando una persona me saluda
las gracias me hice por favor ni se
despide cuando está en una empresa lo
que sucede es pasa por la vida
inadvertida y nunca nos damos cuenta que
existió sin embargo cuando las personas
empiezan a practicar el saludo y
empiezan a sonreír lo que sucede es que
encontramos que hay gente que empieza a
dibujar pequeñas líneas en la vida de
los demás sin embargo cuando empezamos a
practicar el sas o ser cuando saludamos
cuando sonreímos y le prestamos un
servicio a los demás la vida de las
personas se ilumina y cambia de color
por eso quiero invitarlos a que hagamos
una gran revolución esa es la invitación
que quiero que se lleven todos acá
debemos hacer una revolución en la que
recuperemos el sentido de la palabra
servir debemos buscar no perder nuestra
mentalidad infantil que es aquella que
nos permite encontrar una y mil veces
las soluciones a los problemas que
podamos tener con nuestros clientes los
invito a que utilicemos el saso ser como
una norma de urbanístico de urbanidad y
cortesía con los visitantes
y que nunca nunca nunca olvidemos que
las personas que mejores lecciones nos
van a dar en la vida son aquellas de las
que nosotros menos esperamos gracias
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]